joe biden is not a well man
it's not exactly breaking news okay not
exactly a man bites dog story
we know that but the trouble is that
joe biden's unwellness his obvious
decline
tells us something about the broader
democratic party in the broader left
this
was joe biden's rousing campaign
speech i mean this will go down in the
annals of states
statesmen like rhetoric with winston
churchill's
fight on the beaches with ronald
reagan's time for choosing and with joe
biden's muttering incoherently
lonnie knows i believe this every fiber
might be we're posed
what i propose is is it can be done
i think we're in a position to to really
make it happen
and my team and your team are already
working closely together
and like to light up the path forward
here critical laws like the pro act to
strengthen collective bargaining
on politics like prevailing and for look
i guess i'm getting i'm taking too much
time
if you pretend it's slam poetry it's
actually much less sad if you pretend
it's slam poetry it's actually got a
kind of vibe to it you know
we're posed in the pro and the
and the anyway i'm getting ahead of
myself but it's we can all
laugh and in some cases we're not
laughing we're saying this is really sad
no one should let this guy run
his decline his selection the things
he's saying the very fact
that he doesn't know the lingo we're all
talking about shows you
completely how out of touch the
democratic party is
with the united states with the american
people and
why they're just not going to fix it
we'll get into it i'm michael knows this
michael knowles show
[Music]
we're posed on this beautiful thursday
i asked you yesterday we were talking
about some
misleading headlines i asked you what
your
your favorite most misleading headline
of 2020 was
and the answer was from the new york
times elik pointed this out
it was that headline it came out a
couple months ago from the new york
times that said
let's call it the trump virus and i
would agree i mean
it wasn't the most misleading in the
sense that
they've actually just gotten some facts
completely wrong on
russiagate on the 1619 project but the
trump virus
it didn't even really make the argument
that it was trump's fault it was just
that ridiculous headline so fair enough
although you know when you're when
you're talking about misleading
headlines from the new york times it is
shooting fish in a barrel
we will get into that disconnect between
what they're
saying and the reality we will get into
that disconnect you see so much in the
headlines first though gotta thank our
friends over at ring
you know these days it's good to protect
yourself it's good to protect yourself
against people who want to steal
your stuff and there are a lot of people
out there these days who are doing that
ring is on a mission to make
neighborhoods safer their home security
products are designed to give you peace
of mind around the clock
ring gives you protection at every
corner video doorbells let you answer
the door and check in on your home
anytime very helpful to me
i travel even with this coronavirus i
still travel and sweet little lease is
good with a
with a shotgun but i want to make sure
that that i can check in at any time
and it's great even if you're in the
house even if you're at the office you
can check in
and uh just be be with your home even
when you're not at your home
with outdoor security cameras you can
check in on every part of your house
never miss a moment smart lighting
brightens up blind spots
make sure you always come home to a
brightly lit house
really a tremendous product get a
special offer right now on a ring
welcome kit when you go to ring.com
knowles canon k-n-w-l-e-s this is my
favorite thing to give away as a
housewarming present to people
for two reasons one it's really cool and
it really helps you two it's
inexpensive and it makes me look like a
cool guy the welcome kit includes the
ring video doorbell 3 and chime pro it's
all you need to start building custom
security for your home today
ring.com slash knowleskinwlis ring.com
knowles so you biden mutters
incoherently
and that's not surprising at all
but he he also mutters incoherently on
public policy itself so he mutters
incoherently on the culture itself
and he's not exactly alone in this
what what joe biden is showing us is
it's not merely a process
of mental decline you would say it's a
process of political decline
for the left and for the democratic
party joe biden wants you all to know
not only is he posed
but everybody is woked
all the talk the last 20 years about
driving down the rationale for unions
all of a sudden this place this phrase
everybody's been woked
well guess what the rest of the working
class people in america have been
awakened and realized whoa why because i
work at a fast food restaurant that i
have to sign an agreement
that i will not compete a non-compete
agreement that i will not go across
town to another fast food restaurant and
try to get a raise
what in the hell is that about you know
that phrase everybody's been woked
people are attributing this to his
mental decline but it's not that exactly
joe biden is not the first
democratic candidate in recent years to
not understand
the popular culture to not be able to
meme
as we as we describe about the left
hillary clinton you remember
in 2016 she had one of the most cringe
inducing political lines i've ever heard
this was when that app
pokemon go was very briefly popular and
you'd walk around with your phone and
collect pokemon anyway she was trying to
make this cultural reference
and she had this line she she told you
that you had to to take your love of
pokemon
and bring it in to the election booth
because we're gonna have a lot of jobs
jobs from building infrastructure to
coding creating new apps
i don't know who created pokemon go
but i'm trying to figure out how we get
them to have pokemon go to the polls
oh boy oh boy
try try the veal folks tip your waitress
you get it pokemon go to the polls take
my wife please
oh man that is that would be too lame
for like a 40s borscht belt comic
but why why does the left do this
doesn't make a lot of sense because the
left
is the hip young woke cool right so how
come the left
can't meme and that
this is an eternal question it's at
least a question that we've been asking
ourselves for the last four years the
left always says they're the cool hip
future
political movement and yet they can't
meme they can't tell
jokes they can't make people laugh with
spontaneous humor
on the internet they have to go through
these contrived institutions
the reason for this is because the left
controls the entire establishment
they run they run everything we've made
this point on this show before they
control
the mainstream media hollywood big tech
higher education lower education
administrative government they've got
everything okay the newspaper is right
everything and hillary clinton and joe
biden are pretty good examples of this
so they can't meme because to meme
is to subvert the establishment to meme
is to point out an absurdity of the
establishment i mean this is in part
you could broaden this out not just from
internet memes or these little
one-off jokes but humor more generally
humor thrives on
incongruity and absurdity and
recognizing a certain truth
that is not being talked about and
pointing out that truth to highlight
then how ridiculous the
the mainstream established order is but
the left is the mainstream established
order they are the
not only creators of the established
order they're the enforcers of the
established order
and so they can't be funny it's why you
you think of of
political correctness right people
scolding you for telling jokes for
saying words canceling kevin hart
because he made a joke 10 years ago
the left has this problem and they're
trying to work it out now and joe biden
is just
an egregious example of of the failure
of trying to work this out
you cannot simultaneously be the
establishment
and subvert the establishment at least
not in
any serious way you can
you can have the kind of typical
liberalism of the rhetoric of liberation
but
in terms of the actual actual
institutions you can't be the
establishment
and subvert yourself
a good example beyond politics of why
this doesn't work why the left can't
mean why they can't speak to us directly
why there seems to be a disconnect
between the mainstream media and the
american people or joe biden and the
american people
the reason for this is they don't know
what we believe
they have no idea even the most basic
elements of what we believe
they are caught in a fantasy world
the left is living in a fantasy world
that's easy to live in
because it is based on their ideology
the thing about ideology is ideology is
always wrong
there's reality and then there is
ideology which tries to formalize
reality
into a five bullet point manifesto but
that just doesn't work
so they've got this ideology and because
they have the protection of all of the
institutions
they very rarely have to come up to face
with reality when they do
it's at moments where they let reality
have a word in like the 2016 election or
the brexit vote
or a few other of these moments in
recent years and they're shocked they
can't believe it
because they felt so comfortable in
their reality in their in their fantasy
rather
don lemon on cnn goes on cnn with his
friend chris cuomo
and they're talking about how much they
don't like the founding fathers and
we've got to pull the founding fathers
off of pedestals
and the example that don lemon gives as
to why this is the case
is that not even jesus
was perfect when he was walking on this
earth take a listen
here's the thing jesus christ if you
believe in if you if that's who you
believe in jesus christ
admittedly was not perfect when he was
here on this earth
so why are we deifying the founders of
this country
admittedly who's admitting that uh
that guy don lemon is saying that he's
declaring that but
jesus just a little history theology
lesson for you all jesus is perfect
and was perfect when he walked on this
earth
and he necessarily must be that
is perhaps the most basic aspect
of the incarnation he is
god he has to be perfect
don lemon he seems honest when he seems
like he honestly
is ignorant he honestly doesn't know
what he's saying
but consider that i like to think i
don't think we're flattering ourselves
that on the right
conservatives even more moderate people
we understand
the left we we understand the left not
even through any great achievement of
our own just because we live in a
leftist culture so we're confronted with
what the left believes all the time
the left does not believe the right and
to take this matter into religious
circumstances atheists
don't understand christianity
very rarely has an atheist understood
christianity
and rejected it outright i think what
is most evident here is that
biblical literacy the foundation of our
of our education
does not exist on the left they just
don't they just don't know
the most basic aspects and so how could
they comment on it how could they
subvert something
how could they get a funny jive or a
meme
they don't know even most fundamentally
what they are talking about was this
always the case
was it always the case that the life
just didn't get it or has the problem
gotten worse
the left always lived in an ideological
fantasy world but the problem has gotten
much much worse and
actually don lemon proves it to us we'll
get to that in one second
first i got to thank our friends over at
blink sale you should not have to waste
your time creating ugly invoices on your
computer just don't do it it's a it's
a waste of effort that could be spent on
doing the thing that you actually do for
your business
with blink sale you can send beautiful
custom branded invoices
and estimates in seconds you can stay on
top of your outstanding invoices
you can let your customers and clients
easily pay your invoices online blink
sale takes care of it
all so you can spend more time focusing
on the work that actually gets you paid
and makes your business a success and as
an
added bonus right now blink sale is
giving away 10 bucks to 500 daily wire
fans here's how to get it you go to
blinksale.com you start your 14 day free
trial
you create your first invoice of 10
bucks and you activate an online payment
option strive for paypal
then you send that invoice to dailywire
blinksale.com
and you will get paid your 10 invoice
the first 500 people to send an invoice
for 10 bucks
to dailywire blingsale.com will get it
paid by blingsale
limit of one per person unfortunately
otherwise i would be sending very many
stop wasting time invoicing and tripling
sale for free
at blingsale.com knowles that's
b-l-i-n-k-s-a-l-e
dot com slash knowles blink sale spend
less time billing more time doing what
you love
the problem has gotten worse the left
has gotten more disconnected from
reality
you have to look no further for proof of
this than
don lemon himself who just seven years
ago
this was in 2013 i believe don lemon
was on cnn he was talking about some of
the racial
tensions that were cropping up back then
and he he actually deferred to bill
o'reilly he deferred to conservatives he
deferred to people
who were pointing out that most of the
social problems
among black americans don't come from
the cops
the vast vast majority don't come from
the cops they come from social
dysfunction
that has arisen for a variety of reasons
but which can only be fixed
within the black community it's time now
for some tough love on the subject
the reason there is so much violence and
chaos
in the black precincts is the
disintegration
of the african-american family
he's got a point in fact he's got more
than a point
bill raised without much structure
young black men often reject education
and gravitate towards the street culture
drugs
hustling gangs nobody
forces them to do that again it is a
personal
decision he is right
about that too but in my estimation he
doesn't go far enough
because black people if you really want
to fix the problem
here's just five things that you should
think about doing
here's number five pull up your pants
number four now
is the n word now number three respect
where you live start small by not
dropping trash
littering in your own communities i've
lived in several predominantly white
neighborhoods in my life
i rarely if ever witness people
littering
all right slow down there david duke
come on richard spencer
cool it with the racism of course
nothing
he said is bigoted or racist or anything
like that but today
could you imagine if he said that today
we we uh had to play a
slightly condensed cut of that but i
forget who posted it someone posted it
to twitter
you can see the entire link he goes on
and on we actually had to truncate it a
little bit
if don lemon were to say that today on
cnn well he couldn't say it on cnn but
even if you said it on a conservative
cable news channel
i'm not sure you could get away with it
frankly i think you might get cancelled
for it you might be told
that's racially inflammatory that's
offensive that's politically incorrect
even cnn's own hosts
were talking about this seven years ago
the problem has accelerated
and as it accelerates it's going to
create more problems
the democrats would have a better chance
of winning elections the left would have
a better chance of winning hearts and
minds
if they were a little bit more connected
to reality this is the con
great conservative consolation by the
way because the left always takes the
culture
because they promise you free stuff they
don't only promise you free money
they promise you that as well but they
promise you free sex
they promise you free leisure they
promise you
free indulgence of your appetites they
promise you fundamentally
that things don't have costs you can do
whatever you want sexually and not face
any consequences
you can eat as much as you want not face
any consequences you can laze around as
much as you want and not face any
consequences
and the conservatives have to come in
with this unpopular message which is no
everything in life has a consequence you
can't free yourself and liberate
yourself from every single thing in the
world
and even if you did it would make you
miserable
so we're at a disadvantage when it comes
to that kind of messaging
because the left gets to come in and
give you free stuff but
reality reasserts itself in the end
that's the great conservative
constellation because when the left gets
so completely disconnected from reality
people know that
and we joke about that and we laugh
about that and we send memes around
about that
so no matter what they're telling you in
the mainstream media and i think there
are things that the trump campaign can
fix and i think they got to reopen the
country asap where the left is going to
have a real advantage
actually that's another great example
there's now no scientific reason
whatsoever for the lockdown
the lockdown was meant to flatten the
curve so that we could spread out the
cases not overwhelm the
healthcare system we're nowhere close to
overwhelming the healthcare system
we never got close we never even got
close in new york we had
empty hospitals in new york and an empty
hospital ship in new york
there is not one argument for a renewed
lockdown
scientifically but there's a major
political argument for the lockdown
which is that it helps biden because it
lets him stay in his basement where he
doesn't have to talk too much
and it shuts down trump from campaigning
and it puts us on the road to having
national widespread mail-in ballots
which are rife with fraud and we've
pointed out cases of that fraud over
just the past few weeks
on this very show okay that's a this is
a great example actually
of the disconnect between the the
scientific reality
and the political ideology here and
there are a lot of people looking around
and saying wait a second
you told us not to wear masks a few
months ago we see on the cdc website
that masks don't do very much at all
your own arguments are contradictory you
told us that a zillion people are going
to die that hasn't happened
you told us the point of the lockdown
wasn't even to save people's lives
just to spread out the deaths what are
we
doing that moves in
our favor so the left if the right can
wake up to it and finally
actually advocate for our own positions
the left is not in a good place
and we know this because as i predicted
just a few days ago
they are already calling for joe biden
to skip out on the debates
tom friedman the great the inimitable
tom friedman writing in the new york
times says
biden should not debate trump unless i
worry about joe biden debating donald
trump he should only do it under two
conditions
otherwise he's giving trump unfair
advantages first biden should declare
that he will take part in debate only if
trump releases his tax returns
for 2016 through 2018. biden has already
done so they're on his website
don't okay what what does that what do
tax returns have to do with coronavirus
and the arguments against the debates
nothing they just know that it's going
to put trump in a very difficult
position because joe biden
has been on the government dole his
entire adult life and donald trump has
is a businessman so he's obviously got
complex finances and
they just want to open up some new
attacks second biden should insist that
a real-time
fact-checking team approved by both
candidates but hired
by the non-partisan commission on
presidential debates and the 10 minutes
before the schedule conclusion of the
debate
this team report on any misleading
statements phony numbers or outright
lies that either candidate has uttered
there is a fact-checking team at all
presidential debates it's called the
candidates that's what they're supposed
to do
they're supposed to say no you that that
isn't true you just lied about that that
number is not right now what the left
does is they cheat
they put in their own moderators and
their own fact checkers like candy
crowley who did this in 2012
when barack obama was debating mitt
romney and it became a two on one debate
both of the democrats against mitt
romney and she lied through her teeth by
the way
and only apologized after the debate
when no one was watching anymore
they know though tom friedman knows new
york times knows that joe biden can't do
that he's not
up for it he can barely pronounce his
own name and so they're trying to set
the stage
to get biden not to debate as they
should because joe biden
is now personally a little bit divorced
from reality
but more broadly his party and his
political world view
is very divorced from reality now
ironically
at this time of presidential candidates
being separated from reality
we've got a new entrance into the race
kanye west is running for president
i gotta tell you i read through his very
long interview that he just gave to
forbes
kind of like candidate kanye i i know it
sound
i i un-ironically am pretty pro-kanye
i'm going to vote for trump i'm not
going to vote for kanye
in 2020. but i got to tell you kanye has
a lot of good things to say
politically here's just the uh the top
line from the interview
he says he's running for president in
2020 under a new banner the birthday
party
that's the name of his political party
the birthday party with guidance from
elon musk
and an obscure vice presidential
candidate he's already chosen
the vice presidential candidate is just
a preacher i think from the midwest
love that oh yeah are you telling me you
could pick either
like some random congressman some
some empty suit sociopath like most
people choose
for running mates or political
appointments or just a good old preacher
from the heartland of america
sign me up man i'm i'm with kanye he
says
that he's okay with siphoning off black
votes from the democratic nominee
thus helping trump he says i'm not
denying it i just told you to say that
the black vote is democratic as a form
of racism and white supremacy
damn right it is absolutely the way that
they're taught you you see this
constantly people attacking kanye
because he's stealing votes
he's stealing black votes from
joe biden meaning joe biden owns those
black voters deborah messing the actress
said this
just the other day so that's absolutely
disgusting
she said quote he's playing jill stein
he's trying to take young black voters
from biden it's disgusting biden doesn't
own those voters
sorry lady and kanye west points that
out love that uh
he says that he believes quote planned
parenthood's have been placed inside
cities by white supremacists
to do the devil's work yup
preach man absolutely that's the most
concise description
of planned parenthood that i have heard
and their political strategy of
expansion in the cities that i have ever
heard from any american politician
now he's wrong on china he kind of likes
china so that's bad
and he wants to spring people from
prison that's not good we don't we don't
like that very much
but you know he's right on the democrats
he says is the line of his too
let's see if the appointing is it 2020
or it's at 2024
but god appoints the president if i win
in 2020 then it was god's appointment if
i win in 2024
then that was god's appointment what
kanye west is giving here i know
people think that sounds kooky and crazy
this is just a description of what
saint paul tells us in the scriptures
and it's a description of what edmund
burke describes about providence
that there is a an overarching
providence to the world
uh great stuff i dig i like he was he
says that we need to pray we need to
pray for freedom
it's all about god and we need to stop
doing things that make god mad
yeah man that's like my political
philosophy let's stop doing things that
make god mad and pray
and pray for your freedom bingo buddy
man this guy's great i
i can't wait for this guy to run for
president maybe like 2024
i don't necessarily want him to take
over oh on abortion i'm pro-life because
i'm following the word of the bible
oh good stuff this is great on being a
political novice he says
i have to say with all humility that as
a man i don't have all all of the pieces
in the puzzle
he is humble it's one of these things
they say this with trump too they say
he's a narcissist
he's an egotist they say this about
kanye but when you get past the jokes
there is a certain humility here that is
necessary especially if you convert or
revert
to christianity i mean he goes on
there's so many
issues in this whole i i strongly
encourage you
to read this piece there's one bit too i
want to hit on
just one last bit at the end he was
asked about his policies and he says
i don't know if i would use the word
policy for the way i approach things
i don't have a policy when i went to
nike and designed yeezy and went to
louie
and designed a louis vuitton at the same
time it wasn't a policy was a design
we need to innovate the design to be
able to free the mind at the same time
[Applause]
yes that's right that's my view of i
know that's my view of politics though
we have been caught in this technocratic
egghead politics of
just managing spreadsheets what edmund
burke might have called
the sofasters economists and calculators
who he derided and so kanye comes and he
goes yeah i don't want all those stupid
egghead things
i've got a vision we got to pray for our
freedom got to do the right thing
got to stop killing babies i think it's
great it's terrific
i look forward to the future kanye run
he even said in there he goes i'm not
sure i don't have total clarity if it's
20 20 or 20 24.
i if he runs in 2020 that's fine i don't
i think he's probably gonna miss the
filing deadline
and uh you know i like trump so i
that wouldn't be but whatever i don't
care if even if he runs that's fine by
me
all the libs think he's going to steal
votes from biden anyway so whatever
that's what we'll let them
get very upset about that for a few
months but regardless of whether or not
kanye becomes president i'm not
i'm not willing to give my endorsement
uh for president kanye yet
but regardless of whether or not he does
what he says about politics there
has more sophistication and political
wisdom than 100
of uh democrats in terms of actually
like a virtuous politics
and really more than probably 70 percent
of republicans so
i i congratulate kanye i think that's
good also on some good news for our
politics
the little sisters of the poor have just
beaten
barack obama it's amazing that barack
obama
would pick a fight with a group of nuns
called the little sisters of the poor
but he did
he pushed for his obamacare law to force
the little sisters of the poor
and other religious groups to pay for
abortion-inducing drugs and birth
control
in obvious violation of their conscience
this was litigated and went all the way
up to the supreme court it's been going
on for years
and we got a decision and luckily
actually it wasn't even
a 5-4 decision it was a 7-2
decision so you had
the you had i believe it was sotomayor
and rbg
cited against the little sisters of the
poor because
one of those is the least impressive
member of the court and the other one is
the most partisan member of the court
and you had kagan and
everyone else but cake and probably the
most notable liberal go over and side
with the little sisters of the poor
there's just no argument here i mean
it's not even close obviously
the federal government should not force
nuns to pay for abortion inducing drugs
the fact that this is even a religious
question though
should worry us the fact that the state
religion
of liberalism of doing what you want of
if it feels good do it
has this much sway over our religion
traditional religion if you're christian
if this would affect you this could
affect you if you're jewish
or muslim the fact that they have this
much sway
over it is troublesome because it means
this isn't over what the what the left
understands that the right doesn't
is that court decisions are not final
they will keep re-litigating them
until they get the decision that they
want
a nice win for the short term but we're
gonna have to rethink our conservative
legal movement in
the long term i think but for today
let's be happy
and with the little sisters of the poor
and with the little sisters of the poor
and with kanye
let's pray for freedom because this
the state religion is pretty broad you
know there was
a uh there was this this story that came
up
out of canada so it's america's hat it's
not in america but
it's similar ethos and i i wouldn't at
all be surprised if we saw the same
story in america
they in canada they painted a crosswalk
in rainbow colors
not to remind man that god will never
again destroy the earth in a flood
but to to support sexual liberation and
gay rights but now it's so much so much
more than just homosexuality
they're very upset up in canada the cops
are investigating a major serious crime
because they found tire marks in the
crosswalk pride crosswalk defaced
outside west vancouver police station
they're looking for a black ford mustang
with red racing stripes
along the top and sides because there
were tire marks
in a crosswalk have you ever seen tire
marks in a crosswalk
probably you have because you know what
drives over crosswalks
cars you know cars have tires you know
what happens when you hit the brakes
you get tire marks but this is any
offense
to part of the state religion which is
the rainbow
not the old rainbow the new rainbow is
considered
a hate crime the worst possible thing
imaginable we saw yesterday
two people are being charged in america
with civil rights violations with
hate crimes for painting over a
black lives matter marxist slogan
in the streets of a city that sort of
thing that's not going to have to go up
to the supreme court these people are
going to get
the hammer laid down on them whether
it's in america or in canada
and the little sisters of the poor are
going to have to wait and wait and fight
and fight for years and years in court
that is the religion of liberalism
even even this is one story i mentioned
it a little bit yesterday on ben's radio
show but i have to get to it before we
get to the mail bag
single people right now single people
are having kids with strangers
as part of a trend called co-parenting
now
you would think co-parenting is a man
and a woman love each other very much
they get married they call the stork
hotline
the stork brings them a baby they raise
the baby together out of their love for
each other
but liberalism as it always does has
inverted things
so now instead of bringing your love for
another person into it manifestly
a love that is a person and then and
then you give your love to that little
baby
now we only love ourselves we are only
out for ourselves
and everything is about giving us
pleasure and giving us what we want
so the the story goes they're skipping
love and marriage they're going straight
to the part about a baby in a carriage
yelena pronounce a 41 year old account
living in staten island has an 18 year
old daughter
but that hasn't stopped her from
yearning for a brother or sister for my
daughter
after her hubby of eight years made it
clear he doesn't want any more kids
she split from him four years ago and
turned to the internet for answers
there is much that is wrong here but
basically what's come up is that people
go on the internet and they say
they swipe it's like swiping right or
left but not for a romantic relationship
just to have a kid
much wrong with it much is backwards
first of all you want a child to grow up
in a stable loving home not with two
random people who met one time and live
in different places and maybe sort of
know each other but they're gonna have a
kid together
you don't want to intentionally deprive
a child of one of its natural
natural parents which is happening more
and more these days
you don't want to make the kid all about
you
that's the worst kind of parenting and
if you if you begin parenting that way
it's going to have miserable results
that's what our culture has done we've
made it all about us
we've made it all about our own
fantasies and you know what it's done
it's made us all miserable
you can you can see it in public opinion
polls we're more anxious more more
stressed we're more suicidal than just
about
ever this is true across age groups
it's truer of women than it is of men
even
men are committing suicide at higher
rates as they always do but women's
happiness
as measured by various polls has
declined both in relative terms to men
and in absolute terms over the past five
decades
selfishness has made us miserable
that living in a fantasy world has made
us miserable
and i think we might be at a breaking
point i think we might be at one of
these points that happens every so often
every
every few decades maybe only every few
centuries
where reality begins to reassert itself
and people are waking up to that and
that's
an ugly thing when you when you wake up
from a dream
when you wake up sleepwalking things can
go wrong it can be very jarring it can
be very scary
that may be the moment that we're in
this election that we're talking about
joe biden and donald trump
that is that is one symbol it's a clear
symbol of it too
which way are we going to go how are we
going to how are we going to wake up
from this
is it is it going to be nightmarish or
are we going to be happy to welcome
ourselves finally
back into reality that remains to be
seen
we will get to the mail bag in just one
second first though i have got to thank
all of you
for heading over and subscribing on
apple podcast to the michael knowles
show
and i've got to thank you for going and
subscribing to the michael alsha youtube
channel
and i want to thank all of you for going
to my myspace page you know because i
hadn't seen that in probably like
15 years or so and so that was that's
really cool too be sure to check out my
chat with donald trump jr on the youtube
page we we spoke to him yesterday
and we spoke to the man that met the
legend mark mccloskey
he's the guy in st louis with the gun
outside his house
in the pink polo shirt and the white
chinos
he's a hero he clears up a lot of
misinformation that people are spreading
about him
super cool guys so check that out also
get a daily wire readers pass 99 cents
for your first month three bucks a month
after that
you get lots of great insight going into
the election so it's absolutely terrific
head on over to dailywire.com for that
and buy ben's book
head on over ben has a new book out ben
writes a new book every it seems 36
hours
this is a terrific book it's how to
destroy america in three easy steps
he seems to have inv pre-visaged what
what is going on right now uh in this
country people tearing things down he
talks about the
disinter disintegrationists as our
country is disintegrating so you can
pre-order your signed copy at
dailywire.com
ben get that today head on over to
dailywire.com we'll be right back with
the mailbag
first question from josh mr knowles why
does the left seem to only discuss
right-wing straw man arguments when
discussing conservative positions
do they honestly not know conservative
positions
or is it part of a strategy to discredit
those more serious positions thanks
it's funny you should ask that i
actually did not realize that that was
going to be the first question in here
and it ties in exactly to our theme of
the show
and it ties in exactly to don lemon i
think it's two parts one
they genuinely don't know they actually
don't know
and two they don't care
if you live in the liberal world view in
a liberal culture with a liberal
government
you you are generally not very
interested in leaving
that ideological bubble even if the
ideology doesn't totally correspond to
reality you would be more interested in
forcing
that fantasy on the world and making it
into a reality which is a premise of
liberalism
we can do whatever we want to do we can
liberate ourselves completely we can
liberate ourselves from the confines of
reality
that then you are in understanding the
other point of view
but they they don't know what we think a
great example happened this week
ein rand was trending because ein rand
wrote atlas shrugged
ein rand wrote the the fountainhead you
know she was this kind of
anarcho-capitalist type figure she wants
very very small government she just
wants to build things she loved
industrialism she liked
she was an atheist she was a rationalist
and she was famously written out of the
conservative movement when she came on
the scene some conservatives liked
that she wanted to at least make a
little money and save a little money but
whitaker chambers william buckley jr a
lot of people said her vision of the
world
is just has very little to do with the
transcendent moral universe
that conservatives believe in and so
that's not really what conservatism is
but the left was dunking on the iron
rand institute this week
because they took government money and
they really thought that ein rand was
the representative of the conservative
worldview when really that's
that isn't true if it ever was true
that's decades in the past now
and and really i don't think it was true
ever they're they're
tilting at windmills you know they're
they're fighting against
straw men and it's it's why by the way
they
are always welcoming of squishy
conservatives they invite squishy
conservatives on their news channels
they the system actually needs the
squishy conservatives
to give legitimacy to the larger liberal
project
but you know who they don't like
conservatives who tell it like it is
conservatives who are a little too real
conservatives who
who speak their mind and puncture their
ideology who don't accept their premises
they don't let those guys on their news
channels because
those guys rather than being a support
for the system are actually a major
threat to the system and they don't want
to hear it
maybe they don't know about it but they
sure don't want to hear it from pasquale
what a great name pasquale
dear swarthy mr knowles i'm a big fan
also a registered nurse
now i don't have as much medical or
scientific knowledge or experience
as our elected career politicians so i
was just wondering how wearing a
surgical mask
or face covering protects others but not
the person
wearing one many mask wearers
aggressively attack people who don't
wear one but if spit droplets are not
able to go out
wouldn't that also mean they can't go in
either or is that one dollar bandana
made of some magical one-way material
p.s i'm also an italian-american and i'm
extremely offended by your use of the
word swarthy which i'd never heard
before
i'm going to raise money to build a
michael statue then knock it over
because i'm bored and have nothing else
to do
fair enough totally understand that's
the age we're living in you got to build
up statues just to knock them down
on the point about the masks of course
you're right initially
people wear masks to protect themselves
generally speaking
and that was one of the ideas early on
in this coronavirus thing but they
realized that if you're just wearing a
mask to protect yourself
then that gives you the right to decide
whether or not to wear the mask
because in this country we still believe
at least
to a large degree that you have the
right to take some risks
yourself so they couldn't have that
narrative continue
because then no one would wear the masks
and no one would be as freaked out about
the lockdown
and they couldn't push nationwide
mail-in ballet ballots and they couldn't
lock jobin in a basement and not have
them make mistakes
so there were many many implications to
to these policies so
what they had to do was say it's
actually not about you you have to wear
the mask because if you don't wear the
mask
you're killing grandma you're killing
someone else it creates
it's much more effective at whipping up
hysteria and it's much more effective at
getting people to fall in line
but it just doesn't make a whole lot of
sense
when reality reasserts itself as it does
for some people in the end
from aaron hi michael do you think
religiosity will decline in america what
do you think it would take for atheism
to decline thanks
no i don't think religiosity ever really
declines not in the long run
i think religiosity just gets replaced
by another religion
so everybody's got to serve somebody
that is a fact of life man is
fundamentally a religious being
our longings are not primarily just of
the appetite like i need coffee i want
this food i want this drug i want the
sex
we have those longings too but we have
deeper longings
more sustained longings a longing
that cannot be satisfied except with
religion except
by god what you would call the
god-shaped hole in man's heart
that is the most enduring eternal
deepest longing
and so when you that has fulfilled been
fulfilled traditionally everywhere by
religion
but in this enlightened liberal age as
people have
seen it fashionable to become atheists
they just replace it with something else
so they replace it primarily with
political ideology
the ideology of liberalism or communism
or fascism
or they replace it with some kind of
modern spins on those ideologies like
environmentalism which has all of the
hallmarks of religion right it's got
sin in pollution redemption and
recycling
the sale of indulgences and carbon tax
credits it's got
an entire order a moral order that
happens to have to do with the earth
rather than
the metaphysical world but you have to
replace it with something and so
i think there are a lot of squishy
conservatives
the conservative liberals you know the
who the classical liberals even say
who who believe that really what we need
to do
is create this separate space for me to
practice my religion but you're free
not to practice any religion at all and
just every we're all good nobody
has anything to do with each other and
we'll be fine leave me alone
that's not how society has ever worked
that's not how politics has ever worked
politics comes from the greek paulus
the city-states where people live
together that's what it's about
how do we all live together and so it
does have an effect
we got to get this kind of ideological
libertarian notion out of our minds
that we have no effect on other people
and other people have no effect on us we
live in society
we are social creatures that's how
aristotle defines man
and when you're living in a culture that
is a validly atheist or liberal or
environmentalist or whatever
that is going to have an effect on your
religion they are going to come knocking
on your door
ask the little sisters of the poor about
that they've been fighting this for
years
and they got a little mild win but
they're going to be fighting it for
years more i promise you
so the key it is not merely enough to
leave everybody alone what we have to do
if you're christian
is to follow the commission that you are
given which is to
evangelize we we need to persuade people
of our ideas uh if we don't do that if
if we're not winning we're losing from
katie hey michael i'm dating a liberal
here's your first problem things started
off fine but more and more he's trying
to empower me by insisting that i pick
up the check at restaurants and open
doors for him
i don't think it'll work out but i'm
also confused about how to break up with
him
since he already encourages me to see
other men in our relationship
any advice would be appreciated thanks
i can't tell you if that
letter is a joke or is serious that's
how
crazy our culture's gotten that i could
see that being
a joke you know some conservatives wrote
that in as a joke
i could also see that being an article
on slate and i've read articles like
that on slate
and i've heard experiences like that
from
my female friends who have dated
liberals
that's a very bad situation
i guess though we're all focusing on the
guy
this liberal guy who has these crazy
ideas of you know you should
sleep with other men and you should you
should pick up the tab
but really maybe you're the one who's
got a who's who's got the the craziness
here maybe you're the one who's got the
the mental problems you're the one
dating the guy
there's a lesson there for all of us we
conservatives we're the ones going along
with all this craziness
we're the ones not fighting back all
right
one more question from chris hello
michael i keep
reading on places like forbes and npr
that the recent spikes in chronovirus
cases are not due to the recent protests
of course
however i just find that difficult to
believe are they just lying emitting
relevant information or what
what is the cause of this recent spike
thanks keep up the great work
it would seem to me that if there is a
spike in cases
it might have something to do with the
hundreds of thousands of people around
the country
who were rioting for the past several
weeks the fact that public health
officials quote unquote
want to tell you with a straight face
that the virus can discriminate between
political world views and it knows that
it's going to attack and spread among
the conservatives but not among the
leftists
that is ridiculous and the people who
say that have no credibility
and the scientific establishment that's
been wrong at every turn about this
virus
has no credibility
i think the the virus is in many ways it
only occurred to me actually doing the
show today
the virus is in many ways one of these
incidents that is hastening
the final confrontation of at least this
era
between illusion delusion and reality
because we're looking around we're
saying you told us 2 million people
2 million americans were going to die of
this thing within weeks
that didn't happen you told us
flattening the curve was about
spreading out the infections now you're
changing that and saying it's about
saving lives which is not possible
you told us the hospitals would be
overwhelmed that never happened
you told us that it was bad to protest
the lockdowns but then you told us it
was good to loot and riot
for a marxist organization you can't
believe that stuff and i think the most
enduring legacy of the trump era
will be cracking finally
that patina of credibility that the
mainstream media and the political
establishment had
they're not credible they don't deserve
are
our credence they are they are no better
at running this country
than anybody else including kanye west
and frankly
people like kanye west seem to have much
more promise than that desiccated
liberal establishment of both parties
that's how you get donald trump and i
hope that's how you get another four
years of donald trump all right that's
our show
i have got ben's radio show coming up
tomorrow so you can listen then
in the meantime i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy bourie
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
technical producer
austin stevens assistant director pavel
wadowski
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva production assistant ryan
love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
20 20. you know the matt wall show it's
not just another show about
about politics i think there are enough
of those already out there we talk about
culture because culture drives politics
and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are life
family faith those are fundamental and
that's what this show is about i hope
you'll
give it a listen